another art form Donna's famous for
movie posters for years Ghanaian artists
have entertained the world with their
creative renderings of film posters
often for movies they've never seen I
thought I'd pay a visit to one of these
talented painters this is Jasper hi
Jasper Jasper makes many of the great
movie posters here in Ghana and one of
the things you like to do is you like to
make the poster as exciting as possible
even if the movie isn't that exciting
right yeah for example this is the
poster you made for something's got to
give with Diane Keaton I didn't get that
poster but but now I get it yes I don't
think this happens in children of the
corn three so in a way I don't feel bad
for this guy because he was eating an
arm when this guy chopped off his head
so I think he got what he deserved this
is called war bus did you see this movie
yeah bus I thought you saw a war bus
hello the flash isn't it so yeah a lot
of action
I'm a part I think this is a Vin Diesel
movie right it's not yes finished
finished yeah how I thought in this
movie Vin Diesel had glaucoma you gave
him a lot of muscles you even gave him
some muscles that don't exist
look at that it's the first time I've
seen a 6-pack on a neck today yeah just
before coming here
we contacted Jasper and we asked him
would he make a poster for my show the
Conan show yes have you ever seen my
show no you've never seen it do you know
who I am
no you don't so let me get this straight
you've seen the movie war bus yes yes
but you haven't seen my show sure we
ready to see this yeah here's the poster
for my talk show
[Laughter]
this is fantastic there's Andy Richter
yes he has a gun where did you get the
idea that I had body like this what is
happening here with this has had a
dinosaur burn and then Andy's shooting
he's shooting the bird yeah and then
this is the mug the Eisenhower mug
that's on my desk but you've turned it
into the severed head of Dwight
Eisenhower a great American president
yeah that's very upsetting and I'll be
hearing from the Eisenhower people see
you captured my face perfectly look at
this I'm gonna take what you have
painted and now I'm gonna make the movie
[Music]
late night television where everything's
a joke hey Conan I've got to ask where's
Andy and I got an answer who cares
where's your eisenhower bug that's a
double who cares okay one last stitch
what happens when late-night becomes a
late nightmare
[Laughter]
[Music]
together we will destroy coded the
ratings are for terror
[Music]
[Applause]
when your deal with the devil goes south
oh my god it's time for redemption
Conan what have I done
[Applause]
die birth die
Andy Richter Conan O'Brien and Andy
Serkis as the bird
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]